all right let's get ready for week 13.
rams seven and four cardinals six and
five a
a significant huge game in the division
and in the playoff chase because if the
cardinals lose all of a sudden they have
to worry about not getting in at all
here is rams quarterback jared goff from
earlier this week he's been criticized
publicly by coach sean mcveigh here's
goff with his reaction to getting called
out by his head coach
if he was lying i'd i'd feel differently
about it he's absolutely right and i'm a
big boy i can handle it um you know we
have a great relationship and
um i'm accountable for myself and i need
to be better than that i need to take
care of the football and um
he's absolutely right and i will and i
have done that for
majority of my entire football career
and we'll continue to take care of the
football better
three turnovers in the loss at home to
the 49ers last week kyler murray has not
been the same guy since he threw the
hail murray pass to deandre hopkins
nearly three weeks ago they've lost two
in a row since then which quarterback do
you think is more likely to bounce back
from recent rough performances
you know i think uh i i think it's
probably more likely golf because i
think goff his biggest thing right now
is that
i think
sean mcvay does such a great job and
you've seen it over the last few years
since he's been working with jared goff
mcveigh does a great job of looking at
his quarterback and what he does well
and what i think he's going to do
one of the things that's so dangerous
with the rams offense both with cooper
cup and with robert woods
is a lot of the sort of the crossers
and the places where they can get the
ball in short space you know not far
intermediate crossers
and then
take them and use their speed and
athletic ability and ability to make
people miss and make big plays out of it
i'm reminded of the marquis brown play
uh on wednesday
you know the the trace mcsorley to
marquis brown play where you know
marquis brown just makes people miss and
i think that's one of the great things
about the rams receivers i would expect
to see a lot of that
with jared goff this week
yeah and that seems to be the identity
of the rams offense at this point post
todd gurley they've tried to go with
multiple running backs i'd like to see
them settle on one i feel like they
don't have much of an identity in the
running game and the passing game is the
quick crosser robert woods or cooper cup
and we see him take off and get what
they can and not a lot of the ball in
the air down the field not a lot of
movement by jared goff although they do
the bootlegs but but he's not a guy that
you have to worry about taking off with
the football very often he's he's got
limitations in his game and uh the
turnovers clearly a concern and we'll
see what sean mcveigh is able to do to
get more out of him but this is a big
game for both of those teams and they'll
play twice now over the ballots of the
season both week 13 and week 17. the
saints and the falcons just got together
a couple of weeks ago and the story of
that game was the debut of taysom hill
once we knew that taysom hill was going
to be the quarterback many believed
throughout the course of the week it
would be jameis winston hill now 2-0
and
he gets another crack at the falcons but
the falcons get another crack at him one
of the things sims thinks is that the
falcons will take away the run game and
force taysom hill to finally throw the
ball if that's the case do you think
hill is at the point where he can
run that offense from a passing
perspective without the rug threat
he's gonna have his opportunity mike i
think chris is absolutely right in
talking to raheem morris this week
i think he's got his defense i don't
know if you watched a lot of their game
the other day but i was convinced after
watching that game
against the raiders the other day that
raheem morris has added something to
that defense
and that is a physicality and a real
hunting aspect to that defense that
really had not been there
uh in the first four games of the season
and when i look at that game and how
frustrated
you know there are two or three times
where you could just see
derek carr was hugely frustrated in that
game and i think this defense is playing
energetically and this defense
absolutely unequivocally they will try
to make uh
you know they're going to try to make
taste and he'll throw the ball and if
they do that's why i think this is if i
were looking at the game remember
you know mike when
when we used to be a football night and
dan patrick would walk in and he would
say yep here's the upset pick this week
i like the bengals over the dolphins
everybody say oh you're crazy and then
at four o'clock that afternoon we'd say
oh my god
you know bengals killed the dolphins
what happened what did you know dan and
i think this would be dan's game this
week uh atlanta over new orleans
yeah he was right like ninety percent of
the time it was it really was uh yeah
yeah it was the old ef hutton thing when
he would start muttering about the upset
we'd all stop and listen to what dan had
to say because he was right far more
often than not raheem morris showing
that he may be the right guy for the job
peter and you know i'm always a little
leery of making the interim coach the
permanent coach
the only time that's ever really worked
out long term was when jeff fisher
became the interim coach of the houston
oilers in 1994 i mean it kind of worked
with jason garrett although i don't
think at the end of the day he was as
successful as people hoped he would be
specifically jerry and steven jones but
my concern is that you see an artificial
bump from the players who are in the
locker room because they don't want a
new boss deciding who stays and who goes
so let's go out and play extra hard for
the interim coach he gets the job and
then we can go back to stinking again
next year i just i just i've seen that
movie so many times i get leery about
that and uh now that said
raheem morse has had an opportunity to
earn the job on the fly and he's got
five more games to do it and if he gets
to eight and three or nine and two or
even seven and four with the team that
was on five how do you not make him a
serious candy
here's the thing that raheem morris
has to do
and mike he knows it
they have a schedule down the stretch in
which they face
the saints the chiefs and the bucks
twice
okay so those are four games that
probably in every game they're going to
be the underdog
so in those four games somehow some way
he's got to find a way to win two of
them
he just does if you look at their
schedule down the stretch
you know somehow someway
raheem morris has got to get three wins
out of that group and maybe four
but you know i do think
the difference in that team
especially on defense
is so noticeable when you watch him now
the energy they're playing with the
passion the physicality dion jones is
playing it at a pro bowl level right now
and i don't think he was the first five
games of the season so we'll see what
happens but i think he's got his work
cut out for him but either here or
somewhere else if they play well down
the stretch he's going to either get an
interview or he's going to get a job
another dynamic to point out peter
something you said in relation to the
lions at the end of last hour hire the
gm let the gm hire the coach what will
that dynamic be as the falcons look for
a gm are you going to hire a gm and tie
the gm's hands by saying we've already
decided raheem morris is going to be the
coach that limits your universe of
potential gm candidates if part of the
job is we've already hired your first
head coach even though you have other
candidates in mind so i think that
complicates it as well if the falcons do
want to go in that direction it could
make it harder to get the gm that they
want
i think it'd be unfair to hire a gm and
say your coach is raheem morris
i think it would be fair to say
we're hiring you and we're going to sit
down and figure out if our coach is
rahim morris or if there's somebody else
you feel is better for it let's
interview him and let's make that
decision the one difference here is
where he said in detroit
hire the gm let the gm make that
decision
look arthur blank and rich mckay are
going to sign off on this coach
and you know they've been there too long
and i don't think they're going to
abdicate their responsibility hiring a
gm and then saying oh we're going to get
out of the way you hire the coach
rich mckay another example of the best
job to have in football team president
pays well and you don't get fired uh
even when everybody else does i'm not
saying rich mckay should i'm just making
the observation if you're the team
president you are golden because when
the purge comes you're still standing
all right the browns and titans
somebody's going to be standing at nine
and three when this one is done now this
is a game peter i'm conflicted on this
one because i look at it on the surface
and i say this is a clash of titans
literally in one respect eight and three
and eight and three this is game of the
week material remember back when we were
kids and they'd have that half hour
package devoted to the game of the week
it was harry kallus or john fasenda
doing the narration with the slow motion
nfl films you always wonder which game
is the game of the week this should be
it
but until the browns can prove to me
that they can beat a great team i'm
gonna look at this and i'm gonna scoff
and say yeah they're eight and three but
they fattened up on lesser opponents and
they can't beat great teams am i right
or am i wrong
look i look at
what they've done in three of their big
games and again you're gonna say well of
course you're gonna pick out their three
losses six points against the baltimore
ravens lose by 32
uh seven points against the steelers
lose by 31.
six points against the raiders in a
quagmire at home
lose by 10. and you're right mike i mean
they have had some nice wins this year
uh you know they've beaten the colts uh
they won at dallas when that still
seemed like a big deal
so this is a good team it's a good team
but i still want to see baker mayfield
stand in there make some huge plays
and win a game when he doesn't have to
rely on his running game and miles
garrett
you know to me i just i i still am
skeptical about baker mayfield maybe
he'll prove me wrong
uh but at this point
i think a game like this is up to baker
mayfield uh he's got to make big plays
on the road against a really good team
and especially
against a ground hugging offense that
likes to eat the clock
dramatic difference in baker mayfield's
performance against teams below 500 and
everyone else 7-0 against teams under
500 1-3 against the rest of the nfl the
colts was the signature win for the
browns this year and baker mayfield
reminds me a lot of kirk cousins in that
if the running game is there and you
have time to run the pass offense and do
the bootlegs and get out of the pocket
no one's chasing you because the play
action has frozen the linebackers and
you have time to read the field and see
who's open then it's fine but when the
run game isn't there and baker mayfield
is harassed he's not one of those
quarterbacks that when the walls close
in and the play that you've called isn't
working can improvise and make something
happen like the truly great quarterbacks
now he's good enough
but as the browns search
for
better than good enough
i i i hate to say it because
i i'm still kind of on the fence about
what baker mayfield is going to be
but so am i i'm kind of on the fence i'm
on the fence about what he's going to be
and he needs one of these signature wins
that make us say wow he stepped up in a
big moment in a big spot he made the big
throw with a guy in his face and
completed it 30 yards down the field
and they won a game that they were
supposed to lose until they do that
that's how we're going to view them a
team that is getting the absolute most
out of what it has but that it doesn't
have enough to be among the best teams
in the conference or in the league
look what happened when it looked like
that freddy kitchens was the answer for
baker mayfield because they had such
great chemistry together freddy kitchens
gets the job baker mayfield
i don't want to say he's a disaster but
he did not play well and so now they
come back again for another bite at the
apple and they take the guy who loses
out to
uh freddie kitchens in that job and they
hire kevin stefanski and kevin stevanski
comes in praising baker mayfield to the
nines and he's he's great
and so far this year it's been totally a
mixed bag
you know baker mayfield is completing 61
of his passes i don't know what the
average in the league is but that's
below the league average you got a call
you have a head coach who's a
quarterback coach
you know who's with you every single day
and who's making who's calling plays
designed to make you successful you
can't be completing 61 percent of your
throws so that's got to improve and
we'll see if it starts this week in
nashville
and it's going to be a challenge because
the titans after going through a rough
spot middle of the season they've
rediscovered that they need to ride
derrick henry as long as they can he's
been phenomenal the last two weeks had
the big run to win the overtime game in
baltimore took over against the colts
and ryan tannehill told me after the
game we just have to roll with derek
henry as long as we possibly can we've
seen him come on strong
2018 2019 late in the year and he's got
a big push now he's over 1200 rushing
yards already with five games left
if he keeps playing like he has the last
couple of weeks he's going to finish
with one of the best individual seasons
for a running back in nfl history and
it's going to get the titans a division
title and maybe a good spot in the
postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports